[Music]
we have a lot to talk about we're both
hip-hop pioneers that got talk shows
both actresses that got to know I this
is very exciting no from you Conan
exactly your new show this is very
exciting
you did something I have never heard of
before you nicknamed your studio you
came up with a nickname for your studio
yes I call it big sexy that's a great
idea
I mean you know you know that's how you
should feel when you come to the Queen
Latifah show you especially since
there's so many ladies in the audience I
wanted all the women to feel like Queens
when they come in my house so that's
sexy so the studio is called big sexy we
don't have a Nick don't think we have a
nickname for this Navy oh yeah skinny
red-haired man
[Laughter]
there's no Coco love zone but you you
also have a lounge on the set that your
nickname is that right oh the Michelle
Obama lounge
that's very nice you know a girl can
dream right
yes you're naming it to to get Michelle
Obama to come on the show thank you
would be awesome she hasn't been there
yet and the whole set is designed like
like my house basically I'm not that's
the concept you know like you come in
you sit you have dinner at the kitchen
table so I made sure there's a kitchen
you know like a dining-room table so we
can chitchat and there's the lounge
where she is which is kind of like a
family room a den you know so that's the
hope you know that that to come on and
sit in her very own lounge design for
her
that's so optimistic view to think she's
watching right now she's got a lot to do
I've got to see Conan I'll watch Conan
hey then we'll get back to the country
you had something it was all over the
internet you had Dolly Parton on your
show who doesn't love Dolly Parton but
she did something nobody's ever seen her
do before or I had never seen her well
what we've already done you know cuz
we're pioneers and when I were our wrap
planners but you got Dolly Parton to rap
yes that Elise how did you get her to do
that well let's be clear Dolly Parton is
a rapper somewhat before all the country
I don't know what what happens up there
in mountains when you're growing up but
she been spitting rhymes for for a very
long time 50 years that's it yeah so
when she knew she was coming on the show
she was like who we gonna do I'm gonna
do my rap and I'm like you do whatever
the heck you want you Dolly Parton yeah
you know so he got up that she is so
funny I mean it's kind of a it's a kind
of I don't mean this in offensive way
because she said it but it's she's part
of the redneck mafia yeah yeah yeah her
term you know she got her street cred
right so they have a clip of Dolly
Parton rapping and everyone's been
checking this out cuz it's certainly
made the rounds on the internet let's
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
she said she said Miley I got your
wrecking balls right here oh I'm sorry
that was just watching that I gave her
that afro we did Steel Magnolias and
she's she said I got a rap